let's talk to the the women okay so
question
um
I have two questions so I'm gonna ask
both at the same time okay the first
have you ever gone on a date with a guy
that you did not find attractive because
you wanted a free meal yeah and the
second one is have you ever had a friend
that was the whale in this situation
that they're all describing and did you
tell her the truth about what was going
on okay uh first question
um I may have been out with a guy that I
didn't find attractive initially but it
wasn't for the meal
um basically like I think that like
looks aren't everything in a
relationship if if someone has
personality Integrity like has a brain
then that could take you places you
don't necessarily have to look like a
hundred million dollars for me to kind
of like there's other there's other
factors other ingredients that would
make a man
my type
um in terms of the second question
um I would say no because all my girls
are paying like nah there's never been a
situation
that's my best friend all your girls are
paying okay beautiful all my friends
I mean your friend can be pretty but she
could still punch out of her League yeah
exactly like she could be a solid seven
punch into ten but my friends are
smarter than that they would never put
themselves in a situation where like
they're just kind of like okay a hole
I'm sorry like no I disagree single I
disagree I've gone out with a guy yeah
just for mil I mean the guy I knew what
his intentions were but for me it was
never going past
friendship because I wasn't attracted to
him and you just didn't Tickle My Fancy
I mean you were short you was like
nearly just a bit taller than me
and I'm and I'm like a skyscraper over
here
maximum you're gonna be five foot five
yeah was the guy taller than you in
Hills though no no no
and yeah I went out for a meal I was
like you know what he was a persistent
guy as well he kept on like responding
to my stories and stuff like that so I
was like you know what that's it
it's really easy to swipe
that's persistent you thought yeah let
me use man for a free meal because I
just want to eat
that's the foreign
because for me like I said I never saw
it past anything being a friendship
you're a cool guy but me and you will
never ever did you express that to him
like we are not going anywhere past a
friendship yeah we can go out and eat no
I didn't but so so basically you let him
believe that okay boom There's an
opportunity there's a chance but in your
head you know there is no chance bro
like you're not going anywhere with me
yeah yeah I didn't so basically use them
yeah I did oh okay
because the man will take on loads of
dates and these fancy restaurants to
smash and this is why I say like as a
man you have to stay set your standards
like some guys in the beginning they'll
take them to The Shard yeah you can't
you can't blame a woman after that to be
expecting fancy wine and dining and
stuff like that you've got a you've got
a you know feel it out first build it up
a bit a bit a bit and then see if she's
actually you know worth it
a lot of men are simps in it they they
see bomb breast and face and they use
themselves in them a lot of men forget
that what a woman's personality is like
will make me take her to The Shard I
personally I don't take girls on dates
unless I know they're serious on my
girlfriend level but these Sims they see
your pretty face your bum your breasts
whatever it is I don't know it is and
I'm not saying that you ain't got it but
I'm trying to say men in general and
they'll take you to these places to try
to have a transactional experience and
try smash you yeah and now for you
you're looking at the experience in
itself in the general right yeah so even
though you don't rate him you don't seem
in need potential you're saying he's
some free meal right yep so I think it's
a fair game I don't know
though
and ask you a question did you see that
guy ever again after that
um
I did I don't want to bait out how I saw
it how I saw him but he basically came
and gave me like a birthday present
after that
he bought you food you enjoyed it you
went home no kiss no hug no nothing yeah
maybe the church did he get it did he
get a side hug at least
but yeah anyway so what was the question
again
um the first one was have you ever taken
a date from a guy you don't find
attractive and the second one was
um has your friend ever been in a
situation that they were describing and
what did you tell her oh yeah I also
wanted to mention as well based upon
what you said because you said you don't
go out with guys you go out with guys
based on their personality but the first
thing you see you have a guy with
anybody is their looks yeah so the looks
is what's going to attract you your
personality what comes along with it
after and that develops and stuff yeah
so you wouldn't talk to a guy that does
it is not aesthetically pleasing to you
and you wouldn't know that he's a good
guy if if he wasn't aesthetically
pleasing to you just because just
because he's aesthetically pleasing
doesn't make him a good guy
why am I another okay why were you
accept a date with a guy you don't find
attractive yeah because because to me
it's like if if you don't find him
attractive in the beginning that's what
you're supposed to fight maybe I found
them attractive based on our
conversation that we had maybe I found
him attractive based on his warmth you
wouldn't give him the time today
and then no I'm just talking about let's
because more time when you see pretty
girls with ugly guys they've got money
if they've got something something of
value to them right so obviously right
right now let's talk about money because
more time that's what girls go for right
and then when you start going out with
him over time you start thinking oh do
you know what he's actually all right
like he's got some substance to him he
can hold conversations
and as for the whale question there's
always an ugly person ugly girl in the
group no matter how pretty the group is
there's always an ugly girl have I ever
told my well friends Maybe not maybe I
should but at the same time those
friends deal with in their league they
know they're not the best so they go for
like
ugly guys so women always try a day up
they never date down never tell me
something tell them
sorry
I was gonna say well young women need to
do if I was a man
and I took a woman on a date
and fed her I spent my hard-earned money
and not even get the potential of a
relationship at the end of it I'm gonna
be totally pissed off yep because that's
like false advertising I think that when
you go on dates from the time you accept
or you say excuse me but I'm only dating
with the attention
of having a relationship that's what I'm
dating like to vet people
but if you know that instantly you're
not attracted to him
do me a favor just say no say no sorry I
don't see you like that I just see you
as a friend
because otherwise you're just building
them up to fail him and most of the time
it's all the ugly men that they're the
most loyal ones out there
of course and then when people when the
women treat them like this
they just get in themselves and those
are the ones that will go at home
and watch corn and jerk off and then get
fed up with women because of how women
treat them and I'd listen to all these
men earlier that's why I was so quiet
listen to you um about your box you know
the box I'm learning all these new
things
there was another one but I can't I
can't remember
but the women I know there's loads of
women listening to this
the way men were talking about treating
the women to me it was like
cheap these are the you know no value no
whatever
if you know that this is what the men
think of you and the men know you know
that the men want a woman a woman with
low body count
shut your legs
simple don't have no sex
because all the women are going out
there the mother women are going out
there looking for all these
handsome men with money and then they're
going to sleep above all of them
that's how they that's how they vet they
don't vet my conversation anymore they
vet with their vagina
are you not supposed to vet memory of
your vaginas it's supposed to talk to
them
and that's what we're supposed to do and
that's what women are doing now and then
they're complaining that the men don't
want them and the men are saying oh I
don't want a woman with high body can
it's just simple
if the men don't want women with a high
body count and the women want certain
type of men if women decided you know
what I'm gonna shut my legs and only
open it with the intention of a
relationship then the men will get what
they want and so are the women but the
ugly men that use a lot of turning down
I guarantee that they'd be more loyal
and they be the ones that will stick
with you forever then these ones that
have got the money that all flash that
the women are actually going for
because nobody looks at the ugly people
and also I mean I was saying about ugly
women yeah
but I wouldn't go and the thing is when
you're dating you're supposed to be
dating with attention of looking for a
husband not dating attention of looking
you know I do sex exactly if you want
sex nowadays I see and the most it makes
it worse the women are going out there
having loads of sex and then you go to
their house and they've got loads of
rabbits in there and Rosie
as far as I'm concerned
keep your toys and forget about the boys
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible